president Haley looking at trade
does she make trade Freer more
protectionist or
about the same you look at National
Security First
when covid came they told us to put on
masks they were made in China they told
us to take covert tests they were made
in China if you go and get your
medicines guess what they're made in
China we have to go and start looking at
our national security I don't care if
Americans buy T-shirts and light bulbs
from China any more than I care if China
buys agricultural products from our
Farmers but I don't want us to be
dependent on an enemy for things that
Americans need for security that's the
lens you want to look at yes of course
we want free trade but when it comes to
an enemy don't ever be dependent on
anyone else and that's why we need to
build more things in America and what we
can't build in America go to our allies
go to India go to Australia go to Japan
go to Israel those are the ones we need
to be going to